[Music]
foreign
on Radio and on your smartphone this is
talk TV
[Music]
tonight I'll please welcome our sense of
Britain's top Terror Watchdog says Ice's
brides are shamima vegan should be
brought home to face justice but why
should taxpayers be forced to pay for
keeping tabs on terrorists
censored not stirred in our so-called
sensitivity readers Target Ian Fleming's
James Bond novels are they modernizing
the classics or just airbrushing history
we'll debate that but novelist Frederick
Forsyth
plus entrepreneur Vivek ramaswamy is
famous for running his mouth off about
the woke takeover American businesses
now he's announced he's running for
president in his first International
interview he joins me live
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Petersburg Center I'm back
from New York but we're still here and
we're still live here 15 year old in
Britain who's convicted a murder will
automatically be given a life sentence a
15 year old can also apply to join the
armed forces and begin serving in the
next year and they'll also better get
married and start paying taxes in
Scotland the new Trans Rights bill
allows 15 year olds to begin the
life-changing process of altering their
gender with no medical diagnosis anyone
who criticized that law was scolded as a
bigger until the 15 year olds are
perfectly capable of making adult
decisions so what about the decision to
leave your home in East London and join
an Islamic death cult in Syria while
shamima bega made that decision when she
was 15. she left the country that raised
her cared for and educated her to marry
a murderer she joined an Islamic death
cult bent on destroying Western
Civilization through rape and torture
beheading people setting fire to them
several years later when a suicide
bomber killed 22 at an Ariana Grande
concert in Manchester she said this
it's a two-way thing really
because women and children are being
killed back in the Islamic State right
now
and it's kind of retaliation like their
justification was that it was
retaliation so I thought okay that is
a Fed justification
a fair justification that children
who were most of the victims watching a
pop concert were blown to pieces in one
of Britain's most harrowing Terror
attacks
Baker Motor told the times newspapers
are seeing decapitated heads in bins
quotes didn't phase her
most damningly of all perhaps she said
this
yeah I will admit I was the one that
made the choice
even though I was only 15 years old I
did have I I do have like I could make
my own decisions back there I do have
the like mentality to make my own
decision that I did leave on my own
knowing that
begum's Defenders say she's an innocent
child who was groomed that's not how she
sees it though so why should we in
recent years begums attempted to
reinvent herself she has Savvy advisors
and a battery of legal Minds fighting
her case in the UK at vast expense
she started a BBC podcast and the
headscar has been replaced by a cap and
sunglasses a more tick-top than
terrorist state
I think I could very much help you in
your fight against terrorism because
you clearly don't know what you're doing
yeah we don't need any help from you
thanks in our fight against terrorism
begum was rightly stripped of her
British citizenship in 2019 leaving her
languishing in a Syrian refugee camp
last weekend Court upheld that decision
but now the UK's own terrorism Watchdog
Jonathan Hall KC says we should bring
her back
I don't agree other countries including
the U.S Canada and France do this
differently they prefer their homegrown
terrorists to sit in their jails and be
permanently monitored at vast taxpayers
expense but I think Britain made the
right call on this she was our problem
but she chose not to be our problem
anymore
well joining me now is criminal defense
law and human rights campaigner AMA
Anwar and former U.S ambassador Peter
Galbraith well welcome to both of you
so let me start with you uh armor Anwar
I just can't find it in me to see a
credible reason why we should let
shamima begum back given that she also
had Bangladeshi citizenship they may
have renounced it but that's not our
problem she seems to me to be a very
cynical young woman who actually knew
exactly what she was doing I've got four
kids three of them were all been through
their their young teens 15 they know
what they're doing she knew exactly what
she was doing when she got on her path
to Syria she married an Isis fighter who
was committing Terror atrocities she had
three children who all sadly died with
this monster she could see a severed
head and a bin and not be phased by it
she thought the Manchester terror attack
was justified that was the logic of the
death cult she was with I just don't see
why we should be spending a huge amount
more of taxpayer money on top of the
legal bills we've already had to face to
to fight this case I'm just putting her
here somewhere well the first thing I'd
say is that I don't believe that people
that we accuse of terrorism who are
British citizens should be dumped in
other countries that didn't want to the
Syrian people the Kurdish people the
Iraqi people suffered enough with
foreign Fighters come to their land
that's the first thing I would say the
second issue of course Pierce is that
this was an individual at the age of 15
has been accepted by the courts was
groomed was radicalized was then
trafficked and a victim of child
exploitation she was married off she's
not she's not a victim let me finish
she's not a victim she's 15 years old
that you don't get you don't have a
child doesn't get to consent a 15 year
old doesn't get to consent to have sex
and to be married to somebody as an
adult
in Scotland she could say well
you can try and divert the issue I'm
trying to answer no I'm just saying I'm
saying I'm just saying
are you saying no no 15 year old has a
rate of consent that's not that's child
exploitation actually under the law what
I'm saying is we've literally just had
this debate in Scotland where we were
all assured a 15 year old
hang on I'm talking about a 15 year
old's right to give consent about
life-changing things in their life about
child sexual exploitation a 15 year old
under the law of this country does not
have the ability to give consent to be
married off to a man okay and to have
sex with them those people and I agree
with you
impregnated by this somebody was groomed
and ride the class that's the first
thing I don't know what went on ahead I
don't have any truck with her ideas
without Isis and surprising Sunday we've
heard her ideas exactly and I've got no
truck with them because as far as an
Isis is a perverted death call right the
first thing I would say is why should
Syria why should Kurdistan why should
Iraq have to put up with British
Fighters the second issue you raised
about citizenship is this because it
seems to me as though there's two
classes of citizenship in this country
first of all if she was if her name was
Sharon she was white from Manchester
there's no way her citizenship would be
ripped away the second issue is about
you said about having a Bangladeshi
citizenship well actually no because
like for myself I was born and brought
up in this country but by The Quirk of
Fate um I could have my citizenship
stripped because my parents happened to
be of Pakistani origin that's not
acceptable because Bangladesh said at
the age of 19 that they were revoking it
because she has never been to Bangladesh
that's the other part of it living in a
camp of 20 000 Isis Fighters you've
already mentioned the um America Germany
and other countries I have taken back
um terrorist Fighters and the the other
issue I have is this because it wasn't
just 15 euros there was children who
were younger than that who were being
groomed and trafficked by a perverted
difficult sexually trafficked sexual
agreement I would want those like
shamima beggar who tore up the social
contract with this country and went to
join Isis who if they want to come back
to this country then the first demand
should be share the information provide
us the details of those who have gone
into the Shadows who will still be
recruiting who will still be trafficking
and who still want to carry out tax in
this country but also Abode but we
should not under the international law
wash our hands of those individuals who
happen to be British because you would
have been the first of course Pierce to
turn around save the likes of Abu hanza
and terrorist preachers and radical
extremists should be deported back to
their country of origin yet for some
reason because you happen to have a
brown skin because you have to begum
that we shouldn't take responsibility
there's nothing to do with her skin
color I just think she's a disgusting
disgusting piece of work who made her
Isis bride babe well if you haven't
actually stayed out there for many years
you have ever been having repeated
children who died in appalling
circumstances she's shown absolutely
absolutely no sign of real remorse to me
died because Sajid decided to strip her
obviously you're blaming the British
Home Secretary I am because such actions
that she made herself what that child
was innocent the child was innocent and
didn't deserve to die if you have
evidence this is what I believe in this
country we don't we don't rule we don't
have the rule of law which is dictated
by opinion polls by a Revenge mob or
retribution what we have is the rule of
law and if we have evidence of citizens
I'm a British citizen who commits crimes
you can't just bring them back
investigate cute and send them to prison
fine that's what you do it's because we
have the rule of law that the rule of
law has now been applied to her and it
has reaffirmed that decision by Sergeant
Javid that she shouldn't be allowed back
into the country you just talked about
wanting the rule of law to be at place
the rule of law has literally been
implemented the rule of law it was done
on the administrative process under
three panel the judges actually said
that they had grave concerns because she
was about child expectation they had to
deal with it on an administrative
property they upheld the decision
therefore the rule of law has actually
been carried out which is what you
wanted
well you were talking about Scotland
earlier on the law has changed
constantly in this country because of
the public debate homosexuality
same-sex marriage used to be illegal so
what you're saying is do you believe so
you're saying that do you believe
it's like the rule of law that literally
has just been upheld
decriminalizing homosexuality back in
the 60s you are the one who organized
the debate tonight it was your choice no
you asked a question I know I answered
it you know you you cited the rule of
law as being incredibly important I just
said to you the rule of law is literally
just been implemented and it said she
can't come back I want to bring in Jay
Clough now Jay Clough was one of the
survivors of the Manchester bombing
attack Jay thank you very much indeed
for joining me I can't even imagine how
people like you must feel or relatives
of those who died uh and even the debate
taking place frankly that someone like
shamima begum should come back but has
anything you've just heard
persuaded you that actually she should
be allowed to
um
um not not really no and
I think and she kind of made a decision
and she hasn't really shown much remorse
and since in any of the things that I've
Seen On TV she doesn't demonstrate much
remorse and I think the things that she
said about the Manchester Arena attack
um
I we are really terrible I mean you were
there it was one of the most horrendous
attacks this country has ever seen a
deliberate targeted attack on young pop
fans Ariana Grande fans what was it like
for you just having to go through that
um horrendous
taught my nephew to a pop concert and
he's a massive Ariana Grande fan and we
were having an amazing night and he was
only well he was 16 nearly well he's 17.
just turned 17 at the time and and it it
was his first concert and it ended like
that
absolutely horrific and it ended
obviously for so many people and a
completely disastrous manner with so
much loss of life do you have any yeah I
mean sympathy do you have any sympathy
at all Jade for shamima begum's age when
she went to Syria that she was 15. do
you believe that at 15 you don't really
know what you're doing that she was
somehow groomed for this
and I have a level of empathy for
everyone that's radicalized and it's
really sad radicalization is is horrible
but I think because she's shown No
Remorse and since then
um yeah that's kind of my opinion on it
yeah
I want to bring in Peter Galbreath the
former U.S ambassador uh under uh Bill
Clinton Croatia and the UN Envoy in
America Peter Galbraith they do it
differently they basically would let
someone like shamima bacon back do you
think the Britain should be doing that
uh yes in the United States uh we have
brought back our people and uh we have
prosecuted those who who deserve to be
prosecuted and they're serving long
prison sentences so yes I think shamima
bacon should go back to Britain uh and
she should be tried for the crime of
having gone to join a terrorist
organization but tried as a juvenile at
least in the United States a 15 year old
would be tried as a juvenile right but
she wasn't a juvenile for very long I
mean she very soon beddied down as an
Isis Bride for a number of years she had
repeated children none of whom sadly
lived she watched everything that her
husband was doing she saw seven heads in
bins and she talks casually and glibly
about how the Manchester bombing was
justified she doesn't really show any
real remorse people who've been around
her don't think she's actually got any
remorse about it and many people think
she still remains a dangerous person for
this country why should we have a back
well uh the crime was of course going to
Syria to join a terrorist organization
marrying a bad person having three
babies uh expressing disgusting opinions
uh and certainly I think to have
endorsed the Manchester attack as a
disgusting thing to have done none of
those things are crimes I've I've met
shamima a number of times in in Raj Camp
uh at first I I think that her change
from being islamist to being something
else is is genuine but I I don't think
that's terribly relevant I I think the
issue is that she uh is a British
citizen or should be and uh should the
the crime she committed is as a juvenile
now if she committed other crimes once
she was in Syria uh and many of these
people have for example is slaving young
yazidi women or murder then the place
that she should be tried is in Syria uh
because that's where the victims are you
know just because you're British or
American or Swedish doesn't mean you get
a free pass when you commit a crime in
another country you should be tried in
that country that's what the Kurds want
to do and the International Community
ought to help them conduct trials but
once again I know the Kurds have no
evidence that shimima begum committed
any crime when she was in Syria well she
was certainly very aware on a daily
basis of the horrific crimes being
committed by her husband and by other
Isis Fighters and I I would take issue
with this idea that a lot of people have
said they've met samima begum and think
oh she's not dangerous anymore people
would have said that about it before she
went
there was no sign of this radicalization
for family and close friends so I think
she's extremely cynical manipulative
woman who continues to pull the wool
over people's eyes and in terms of her
citizenship it is complicated of course
by the fact that she also would qualify
as Bangladeshi and the Bangladeshi said
they don't want to back either so that's
why she's stateless it's not just
because Britain doesn't want it
well uh I I I I don't you know I I I
think that um uh she she has you know
there's no evidence again that that
she's committed crimes
um what she's been in Syria and if she
has then that's the appropriate place to
do it to try her
uh you know I I want to say something
else about this because
um I brought out a number of children
from Ross camp but I've also brought 26
children born to raped yazidi girls
kidnapped and raped by the Islamic State
uh and then their children were taken
away from them after the Islamic State
fell and and I got some of them 26 and
after two or three years and where are
those children and mothers they're
they're in safe houses in Iraqi
Kurdistan because countries are taking a
long time a very long time to process
them so I wish that some of the human
rights activists who have taken up
shamima's cause would also take up the
cause of the victims again I do think
that shamima
ought to come back to the United Kingdom
precisely because she committed the
crime as a juvenile and and instantly in
Britain uh you know yeah I was looking
this up it turns out that if you commit
murder you're generally eligible for
parole after 15 years and yet in the
first decade of this Century there were
30 murderers who went on to commit
murder why hasn't Britain just had life
means life and you never get up but you
don't do it that way uh and yet it can a
person who's committed a murder or a
serious assault is of course always at
risk of doing it again and yet your
society allows those people out I think
the chances of shamima committing
another crime or a terrorist act are
very very small certainly less than
somebody who committed a murder or an
assault okay Peter Galbraith you raise
interesting points I don't agree with
all of them but I respect your right to
have that opinion uh thanks also to Emma
and well thank you very much for coming
in and to Jay Clough and Jade I wish you
all the very best I'm sure it's an
ongoing process for everybody that was
involved in that horrific night and I
wish you all the very best
it is
thank you
well silicon first I came for Royal Dahl
now Ian Fleming's classic James Bond
books are getting the sensitivity reader
treatment are they modernizing the
classics or just airbrushing history
well to make that a novelist Frederick
full side that's next
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
ER join me on first edition a brand new
current affairs program which brings you
tomorrow's news today first edition is
about making sense of what's really
going on in politics on the economy and
across the World At Large music makes
sense opinions that matter so don't miss
first edition with me Tom Newton Dunn
each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
Fleming's James Bond novels are being
Rewritten by so-called sensitivity
readers the classic books will be
republished in April to Mark 70 years
since Casino Royale but they'll feature
a disclaimer about offensive terms and
attitudes and a number of so-called
defensive references will be removed or
reworded in Live and Let Die bonds
assessment there would be African
criminals in the gold and diamond trades
are Petty pretty law-abiding chaps I
should have thought except when they've
drunk too much just becomes pretty
law-abiding chaps I should have thought
in Dr No the race of a doctor and an
immigration officer now got unmentioned
as does that of a henchman shot by Bond
the use of the n-word has been
completely removed but references to the
Sweet Tang of rape blithering women and
homosexuality being a stubborn
disability will they remain joining me
now is the author of classics by for
Another Day of the Jackal Frederick
Forsyth alongside political journalist
Avis and Tina and talk to me contributor
Esther Kruger well welcome to all of you
thank you thank you I mean I thought I
mentioned that dresses probably very
inappropriately and someone somewhere
will be offended but thank you is this
all for me for my I come back from New
York of course and a very smart suit to
you Freddie as well
um before we get into this I want to
just quick reaction to shamima bacon
should she come back and face trial here
I think this is if there's a genuine
charge that you can be subjected to she
should be brought back in charge and
tried I think that trial trial would
like to last about an hour right before
we quit I mean to me Ava the deal is she
all right she was 15 when she first went
but we've literally just been told by
the people of Scotland the Nicholas
sturgeon for months after month that a
15 year old can make life-changing
decisions about their gender what's the
difference that's a ridiculous question
why because it's not a question you know
I actually would pull the discourse
right back and I would say what is being
British and what is our prison system
and if our prison system is not up to
scratch to deal with someone who has
potentially joined a terrorist
organization
why should we spend taxpayer money
because she was born here because she's
our property she's also like she also
has Bangladeshi citizens
she's never born
they did reject him but she she could
qualify for censorship there not just
here Esther I've got no sympathy for
samima Baker and this sort of this this
celebrity tour she's been going on yeah
fueled by the BBC giving her this
massive podcast fueled by magazines and
so on I just like clearly it's a PR tour
look I think the one thing I I don't
think can wash as an argument is that
she was groomed unless at 15 you had the
IQ of a carrot she knew that joining a
terrorist organization was a very bad
idea
I'm sorry
my 15 year olds my sons were 15. I
didn't need to sit him down and say by
the way if you go and join a terrorist
group where they cut people's heads off
yeah set fire to human beings in cages
that's not a good idea okay I didn't
need to have that moral chat with them
they kind of knew yeah you know what a
15 they know my daughter is 11. she
knows yeah but I do that poor little
shameema begum she's 15 therefore she
didn't know anything about what she was
doing she got her way out there I mean
that alone was pretty good yeah but I've
sat here and I've heard discussions
before about 15 year old men not have
they shouldn't be responsible for sexual
assault that they might have perpetrated
because they're too young and they
didn't understand the ramifications of
it how is that any different 15 is
either too young to consent or at Israel
excuse me of having a terrible argument
using the gender debate in Scotland
which one is it but also the government
is terrible that's many are you using it
yourself the age for criminal liability
in this country is actually 10. so I
think we need to start there you cannot
say that she cannot be held criminally
liable if a 10 year old can be but she
can't be groomed she can't be groomed
because she's not sick she was a
straight A student before she left she
managed to get to an airport she can
read and write okay look I'm talking
about reading and writing let's move on
but I want to move on uh Freddie to this
this I mean the moment I hear things
like sensitivity readers being employed
by Publishers to go back over old
classic books Roald Dahl in Fleming or
whatever I think this just have the old
never done this for a while
[Applause]
but the world is going nuts isn't it
Freddie what are we doing we're going to
just leave these bugs alone well I saw
all part of this thing called um workism
yes do you know what that is yes it's
the new dictatorship yes it's a new
fascism right it's the kind of fascism
is because it says you will think the
way we think you will talk the way we
talk you will believe what we believe
uh that way lies and we will control you
and we'll go back in history we'll be
controlled and we'll go back in history
and we'll apply today's slightly warped
Morality In many cases would apply the
rules of today the woke rules will apply
it to if you try the Bible books in
history whether it's a Bible would
survive well the Bible wouldn't survive
Shakespeare wouldn't survive no Opera
would survive I mean eight percent Tina
I know you love this stuff this this
wokery but nothing that I'd like in the
world would survive this this purge I
don't I mean that I don't think that we
should rewrite it but not for the same
reasons that you do I I think that what
I don't understand why a book would have
to have the n-word in it or any of these
slurs to begin with and I think that he
should hang for that I think that you
know people should be able to read that
now and know that their favorite
franchise is actually rooted in racism
okay but do you also want the n-word
expunge from all rap lyrics or is it I
don't think that's a question for me I
think that in context I think so like if
I can understand why that is in the
needed to use it when actually those
books weren't written that very long ago
you could you could feel necessary okay
so Esther I would say there is certainly
an argument to remove say the N word
personally I sort of agree with you
right although I do have a big problem
with rap lyrics continuing to propagate
words like that all the time so the kid
just sends a wrong message to the wrong
people who then think it's all right for
them to use it but on this General Point
some of the changes being applied to
Roald Dahl were ludicrous yeah it's a
brilliant investigation by the telegraph
incoming fantastic some of these changes
on bond I mean they go to a strip club
right bonds visiting Harlem in New York
and there's a strip club there's a male
crowd getting agitated before it read
Bond could hear the audience panting and
grunting like pigs at the trough he
filled his own hands gripping the
tablecloth his mouth was dry right you
might think all right it's a little bit
you know near the knuckle but that's
probably a very good description of
exactly what was going on with that male
crowd of that strip club it's now bonds
could send the electric tension in the
room the sensitivity reader has taken
quite a quite sort of colorful
description of a strip club scene in all
its you know dinginess and turned it
into the most dry boring pathetic thing
as if something
but the thing is
it terrible right you have to remember
is he a good writer I reckon yeah I
think he is no but here's the argument
you have to remain true to the vision of
the author you cannot tell on an author
what they actually meant to write they
wrote what they meant to write but I
think one why are why is there a
hierarchy of what's offensive so you can
remove the n-word but you can't remove
glorification of rape or clear
homosexual slurs and also how do I
become a sensitivity reader because that
clearly is a gift well actually too well
actually my wife's sale is done a piece
of telegraph tomorrow in which she found
out and apparently you can literally do
an online course and within one week you
are deemed qualified to be a sensitivity
reader that that is absurd I mean
literally it's ridiculous this is I mean
funny has anyone come for you yet have
your book's been I don't think read
sensitively I don't so far I think not
like
how would you feel if they did well I
wouldn't give a damn would you let them
do it you can't stop them you can you
can see you're not publishing my book
oh
yeah well no I don't think it was well
it hasn't put it so it hadn't happened
so our weekly does happen when you saw
the role of what they'd object to I
suppose of a description of a gun
perhaps I just think a lot of this stuff
it's a bit like the Roald Dahl ones some
of it I can I can understand the
argument about whether the n-word should
be published at all in a book in a
derogatory manner I can completely sign
up to that so it's not like I think
there's no rule at all that can be
applied in in removing things which are
absolutely grotesquely offensive but
most of this other stuff is to me it's
inconsistent and in the case of Roald
Dahl completely nonsense they said it
was wrong it was offensive to call
someone fat yeah but they could call him
enormous okay but I do think Roald Dahl
should have been on the curriculum in
the first place I don't think children
should be reading why because this
family after he died posthumously
apologize for his anti-Semitism no no
that's about it is but that's about his
own views right so you think that anyone
with dodgy views all their work should
be expunged I think if you were a Nazi I
don't think that you should be on the
school
these were private views which he then
made actually I don't know in that if
we're gonna we're gonna name it in the
twits you know there are references to
long noses or there's been pieces
written about that which is you know I I
don't think I'm actually a complete
absolutist in this regard I don't think
you should censor any books I don't
think you should rewrite any books I
think if you want to you can have a
disclaimer so that you can have a
discussion about it you would hate the
disclaimer that you would advocate for
that
all you can choose just not to read the
damn books right I mean just don't read
them but would you not do you not think
that children should read and they
should get immersed I think children
I've got four kids from 30 to 11 right
nearly 30 to 11. they have
read a lot of books which have probably
challenged them scared them made them
laugh made them cry right I want them to
read stuff that actually brings out
emotions in them I don't want them
protected and causative I don't want
them reading Roald Dahl and someone
putting little cotton wool over their
face make sure that little Johnny isn't
upset it's like no I want you to be
challenged okay would you let them read
Prince Harry's book without any
one my son's turning here to be a drip
like that I don't I wouldn't let him I'm
just on Humanity grounds Freddie where
does it all end as you said there's no
Bible if this goes on there's no
Shakespeare
um either they'll come for the Beatles
they'll come for everyone once the woke
virus infests itself into any form of
culture it destroys it whether it's
historical statues whether it's books
whether it's movies when they came for
Baby It's Cold Outside that's that great
song in the 50s and and tried to pretend
it was about sexual assault and the
person who led that campaign was John
Legend who rewrote the lyrics whilst
saying nothing about his rap mates Who
come out with the most terrible awful
misogynist lyrics I I at that point the
debate lost me completely yeah I know
there is no logic to it
um and the there's actually there's no
Humanity to it it's not about protecting
you from being shocked which is the idea
it's about control yes we want to
control you we're a tiny minority but we
would very much like you to think the
way we think do what we do say what we
do what we say read what we read yeah
that way lies control if you look at
every dictator that ever won yes what
did they try to control the education of
the children and the media what did Mao
do right
exactly what they did what happens in
North Korea if you try and read books
they don't they stop you yeah I don't I
don't quite understand the argument
because I mean if you turn on the
television if you watch any broadcaster
at the moment you will hear exactly the
same point of view in exactly the same
line I don't understand
no but all News broadcasters teach you
exactly the same thing propaganda is
very much alive but it's not in
rewriting a little bit of literature
look stay here Pat because it's actually
one of the great packs of all times I
think isn't it it's basically Beauty in
two weeks right so we're going to keep
it
so so we're gonna we're gonna kick you
for if you don't mind staying around it
no we're going to talk to a presidential
candidate in a moment a young man very
dynamic in America if something else is
running for president he's got everyone
going very interesting exciting guy he's
a multi-millionaire and entrepreneur
he's on an anti-wolf Crusade which is
why I want you guys to comment after us
it's going to be his first International
interview since announcing his candidacy
Vivek ramaswamy is live next from the
United States
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on Politics
on the economy and across the World At
Large music makes sense opinions that
matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
this is
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
well I'm not saying this show has
particular Powers but a few weeks ago I
interviewed a young man who came on and
was very impressive on Piers Morgan
uncensored and the next thing is running
for U.S presidents
and he's running really is the first
properly anti-woke president of the
United States entrepreneur and author
vivet ramaswamy is a self-declared
America First conservative running for
the Republican nomination he's promised
to defend America against what he calls
the secular religion of wokism which
we've just been talking about so welcome
back uh Vivek great to see you was it
was it the appearing on Piers Morgan
uncensored that drove you to announce
your candidature
I think it must have been just a
subconscious urge you gave me that's
right I didn't realize until you
mentioned it there but but it must have
played a role well listen good to see
you it's exciting uh you running I think
you've energized the race and it'd be
very interesting to see how far you can
take it the great elephant in the room
in every sense of course is Donald Trump
and the recent Fox News poll yesterday
showed Trump with a massive lead even
over his his second uh Place person Ron
DeSantis and then a huge gap back to the
rest of the field including yourself how
can you Barrel your way past Donald
Trump to win the nomination
so I view myself as building on the
foundation that he already laid taking
America first to the next level but I
say this very clearly appears in order
to put America first we in this country
have to ReDiscover what America is and
if you ask most people my age in the
country today really any age in the
country today what does it mean to be an
American today you get a blank stare in
response and the Hallmark of my
candidacy is that I'm Reviving the
ideals that set this nation into motion
250 years ago from your side of the pond
set this nation in motion not only 250
years ago but the ideals that Define it
today basic ideas like Merit that you
get ahead in this country not in the
color of your skin but on the content of
your character and your contributions
free speech and open debate the radical
idea that the people who we elect to run
the government
ought to be the people who actually run
the government I think most people agree
on these basic rules of the road
regardless of partisan affiliation but
very few candidates are talking about
this issue of national identity and
that's what the heart of my campaign is
all about is Reviving this missing
national identity in America my travels
of this country suggest that people are
hungry for it they're starved for it and
so far I'm beginning by saying the
things that other candidates are not
willing to say in polite company but
which are just fundamentally true from
ridding ourselves of the cancer of
race-based affirmative action to
abandoning this climate religion that
shackles the West while leaving China
untouched and I think people know deep
in their bones these things are true
need to be said and most importantly
need to be delivered talking of truth I
was in New York last week and
interviewed George Santos this
Republican congressman who has told so
many lies it's impossible to keep up
with him and eventually I just put it to
him that he might just be a terrible
liar here's a clip
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure like I
said well I've been a terrible liar on
those subjects
kind of stunning that to what you're
serving U.S congressman just brazenly
admit I'm a terrible liar and still sit
there
serving the American people it might be
it might be the most truthful thing he's
actually said and it might even be more
truthful than many other politicians
actually so the irony is that you know I
don't give him a lot of credit for much
but I give him credit for saying that
because there's a lot of other people
peers who are sitting in Washington DC
who could call themselves terrible Liars
too and I think that that's part of why
bluntly I respected Donald Trump for
what he did coming in as an outsider in
2015. you only get to be an outsider
once though I'm coming in as a new
Outsider as far as I know I'm the only
real Outsider in this race and you know
what at a certain point you become a
creature of the very swamp that you
wanted to drain you become a creature of
the government that you wanted to reform
I'm coming in with an agenda to do
something that I haven't heard from
other candidates shut these agencies
down so I've already committed to
shutting down the Federal Department of
Education in the United States it has no
reason to exist other than to cause
greater problems and spend money I'm
going to identify a list of other
agencies we intend to shut down to I
want to fire over half the federal
employees I actually think that that
would be good for the federal government
not just in terms of saving money but
restoring Democratic Integrity that is
speaking truth but you know what maybe
after eight years on the job I'll be
like one of them too which is a good
reason why I need to get the heck out of
the way but right now is just a fresh
perspective and shake it up I think
you've got a very Dynamic style a very
Dynamic message don't agree with
everything you say but I I like the way
you say it all but you still not really
address the original question the
elephant in the room because to achieve
any of the things you're talking about
you've actually got to win the
Republican nomination that will give you
the chance to then potentially win the
White House and be president and do the
things you want to do and as you know
Donald Trump still has this massive
Stranglehold over the Republican Party
how are you going to beat it because
I've known Trump a long time right in
good times and bad we've had great
friendship we've fallen out a few times
always fall back in is fine but the
thing about Trump is you're either all
in or you're all out there's no sitting
in the middle there's no like you know
what I like the guy but I still want to
beat him if you want to beat him you've
got to say how you're going to do it and
he's going to come after you you know
that
so I'm going after this under substance
periods and I I traveled Iowa and New
Hampshire those are the early voting
States here in the United States I had
many people who came in there was
actually one elderly woman but many she
was caught on camera but many others
said the same thing which is you know I
want I liked what you had to say maybe I
want to see be Trump's VP now I'm moving
to you why was that because it was
because of the specificity of what I
said I'm going to deliver you know just
take this example of affirmative action
right most Republicans hate affirmative
action as do I but very few have done
anything about it and it was because of
a Lyndon Johnson executive order in
America that mandated race-based quotas
in the private sector for any company
that did business with the government
every Republican president Donald Trump
included could have taken a pen and
crossed it out they chose not to for
fear of political backlash I don't have
that fear and so in a certain way I
think what I'm going to be my candidacy
is going to be defined by the substance
and specificity
by looking backwards and complaining all
right you have age on your side clearly
of your young Dynamic persons said Nikki
Haley one of your other Rivals now
running for the Republican ticket she
says effectively Donald Trump and Joe
Biden are too old it's time for a new
generation do you share that view
so I don't quite share Nikki Haley's
view because I don't believe in
eliminating the competition if you want
to be the leader of the Free World you
do it by convincing the voters of the
merits of your vision over somebody
else's she picked 75 arbitrarily because
Donald Trump's 76 if Trump had been 71
she would have said 70. I think frankly
that's a pretty lame approach to
actually try to eliminate competition I
think we should have it out in the open
have the open brawl debate it out in the
open and I think that the best ideas and
the best candidate to carry those
forward ideas will win and I'm running
because I believe I'm that candidate so
you believe you're worried about Trump
so because the bigger threat you become
the more Trump will come for you we've
seen it with Ron DeSantis who he calls
Ron super silly is whatever it is uh is
your message to Donald Trump if he's
watching I'm sure he is he's a big fan
of Piers Morgan uncensored if he's
watching is your message that you're
going to beat him
my message is I'm going to win this
election because I wouldn't run for
president of the United States if I
didn't intend to see this all the way so
you're going to beat Donald Trump
look down the barrel and say Donald I'm
going to beat you
I believe that's what I'm doing that's
what I'm setting out on this election
I mean talk to you we'll stay friends
after I mean talk directly to Donald
Trump imagine he's watching which I
think he will be just say say to him
what that you're going to beat him
I love your energy man I love what
you've done for this country you're an
inspiration to what you did in 2015 now
it's my turn we're taking this forward
and Reviving America something you care
about something that I care about and
hopefully we can work together to do it
in some way because it's going to take
every one of us to revive this nation
and I'll tell you this too okay to be
really honest about it if you can't
handle some name calling I see other
Republican candidates whining about this
possibility if you can't handle being
called a name in this country you
probably shouldn't be the person
representing this country sitting across
the table from Xi Jinping we all need to
toughen up a little bit and I think that
all of us do genuinely care about this
country I'm running because I I believe
that in all seriousness and joking aside
peers I care about this thing called
National unity in the United States and
I think Donald Trump is misunderstood I
think he cares about National Unity a
lot too even though people misunderstand
that about him but the question is who
can actually deliver it right now and I
think that if it was going to have been
delivered it would have happened already
we need a different approach to uniting
this if you're going to win if you're
going to win I've got to wrap it excited
because I love talking to you but um if
you're going to win
are you suggesting that maybe Trump
could be your running mate
I would take him as an advisor you know
what I would take his advice on
reforming the administrative State I
want to shut down those agencies he has
some experience trying I want to benefit
from his experience so I'll take his
advice at every step of the way I bar in
this primary I'm gonna thoroughly enjoy
that's why I'm running I'm going to
thoroughly enjoy telling Donald Trump
that you have kindly offered to employ
him as one of your advisors uh Vivek
ramaswamy you're an excited advice is
what I would say thank you you're an
exciting candidate I'm glad you're in
the race I think it's what it needs a
bit of energy and dynamism and it'd be
very interesting to see how far you go
but it's great to have got to know you
on the show please come back again soon
appreciate it man actually final
question before I let you go
final question should James Bond books
be censored
no it's a hard note of that answer okay
got a double 07 answer to that question
it's sort of like uh you know take aim
at whatever that problem is and uh and
and really say we're done with
censorship in this country on both sides
of the Atlantic I'd like a straight
answer to a straight question Vivek
thank you very much
thanks man
interesting character uh well next
tonight Boris Johnson said he'd get it
done he then falsely claimed he had got
it done turns out he hasn't got it done
at all and the oven ready deal was burnt
so now it looks like Rishi sunak has
come along taking it out of the oven
cooked it a little better and we have a
better deal or do we where's Boris does
he run to a fridge again to avoid having
to be part of this we'll discuss this
with the pack after break
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large music makes sense
opinions that matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
this is
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk Rishi soonite
finally gets a breakthrough brexit deal
or does he we're debating if Posh actors
should be banned from playing working
class roles and find out how you can ask
Prince Harry a question for the bargain
price of just 19 quid all of that at
nine o'clock
foreign
Aver let's talk brexit for a minute
Freddie because uh are we are we in a
better place with this deal I mean I I
voted against it from the start but are
we in a better place if you were a
brexiteer uh I think so yes we are there
was it was the one unfinished issue
uh after after the the brexit vote the
one that was held civilian suspension
what about Northern Ireland why was it
never sorted before we all went to
because it's a split country the island
of Ireland is divided into two yeah
there are very few countries in the
world and most of them are a dispute
with each other that are divided between
two either two ethnic groups or two
religious groups
uh and in the case of Northern two
political groups you were you were
brexitier right I was a brexiteer yes
well you're still a brexit you still
think it's a good idea but not for that
reason not I have anything against
Europe but certainly not a Europe indeed
I found it being a big big hit I've been
known to about 25 countries in Europe
and speak five of the languages so yeah
I love Europe that's not the problem
what's the best foreign language you
speak
um well I used to pass a French among
the French and German among the Germans
give me a little dash of something and
what well give me a little bit of it
okay
uh anyway brexit it seems to me seven
years ago we voted in this referendum
three years ago brexit got implemented
we're still trying to work out what to
do about Norman Island which seemed a
big problem to start with and I can't
see any tangible benefits to brexit at
all at the moment well certainly not to
the new uh protocol that has now been
rearranged I mean even after all of this
has gone through if it is to go through
you know Northern Ireland is still
potentially going to be not aligned with
the UK the EU can still change laws that
Northern Ireland can agree to so they're
still not actually Sovereign the way
that it's being sold you know this
afternoon that it has been and I think
that's the thing because it's it's such
a it's such a unique situation you have
to keep the Integrity of the Union but
at the same time something like brexit
has never happened in our history so how
do you straddle those two lines and I
think this is the best we could get I
don't think people understand the
gravity line I did the best we can get
but the thing is I don't think we want
to understand the gravity of the
situation the longer this drags on the
more precarious the UK looks it's
dragging on for seven yeah
there's a reason why Britain is growing
at a slower Pace than the rest of the
Jesus exactly right and it's not because
we didn't all get hit by the same
pandemic or the same energy crisis or
the same war in Europe it's because
brexit has made it worse here yeah and
until until this tangible benefit I'm
not I've always said I I was Voting
listen I lost right a very remain but
I've always said I respect the result
but at some point it has to work ready
yeah won't you uh I think you and a lot
of uh those who support him or oppose
brexit failed to realize it was not the
pact of being in Europe it was they were
in under punitive terms imposed by
George pompidou the loyal servant and
follower of Charles de Gaulle who was
passionately anti-british throughout now
if you look at the history
Milan tried to get in under yeah but I
don't dispute any of this my issue is
that right now seven years after the
referendum I don't see any benefits of
it that's because I think we haven't had
a dynamic prime minister we've got a
mini left I want to talk about toxic
femininity I'm not putting it here for
any reason Amy said Cena but apparently
though the men on love Island they're
blubbing like big babies because the
women are being Beastie to them and
they're toxic I mean I could have told
them that was a real problem wait who's
toxic in the situation we were talking
earlier look the women aren't toxic but
also have you ever had a boyfriend that
hasn't cried absolutely love it really
you would have done it
you can pack it in okay husband
Freddie great to see you thank you I
miss your new books at least you get
excited about it come out of retirement
come on write a new one the Box oh no I
see any of them love them thank you Pat
lovey to see you that's it for me what
are you up to keep it uncensored
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large music makes sense
opinions that matter so don't miss first
edition with me Tom Newton Dunn each
week night at 10 pm